hello again let's go straight back to
the old Bailey um because the crown
prosecution service have just made a
statement that's following um that
sentencing for David Smith the former
Berlin Embassy Security Guard who was a
spy for Russia he's been jailed for 13
30 years and two months let's have a
listen
David Smith who has just a few moments
ago been sentenced here to a substantial
uh custodial sentence was motivated by a
combination of two things
greed and a hatred of our country
that hatred
was palpable
and led him into engaging in what can
only be described as really despicable
Behavior
I hope the sentencing today sends out a
very clear message
to all concerns in terms of engaging in
this sort of behavior
the crown prosecution service has worked
very closely with a metropolitan police
who have conducted a meticulous
investigation in this case and I will
conclude simply by reiterating
I hope today's sentence sends out the
very clearest of messages in terms of
this sort of behavior thank you very
much